مستمرون معكم مشاهدينا في هذه التغطيه
لاثار الزلزال العنيف والمدمر الذي ضرب
تركيا وشمال سوريا اعداد القتلى في ارتفاع
مستمر وتتواصل عمليات الانقاذ بحثا عن
ناجين تحتها الزلزال بلغت قوته قرابه 7.8
درجه وتحدثت السلطات التركيه مشاهدينا عن
انهيار 130 مبنى في عشر ولايات وزير
الداخليه التركي اكد ان عمليات الانقاذ
مستمره للوصول الى المحاصرين تحت الاوقات
ودعا ايضا مواطنيه الى الكف عن استخدام
الهواتف المحموله
طبعا نشاهد معكم مشاهدينا هذه الصور
المباشره لفرق الانقاذ وللاشخاص يحاولون
مساعده ما يمكن مساعدته وانقاذ ما يمكن
انقاذه يبحثون تحت الانقاض يبدو انهم في
حاله بطبيعه الحال من الذعر والهلع والقلق
والترقب لما سيكون تحت هذه الانقاض من
احياء او اموات او مصابين سنتحدث مزيدا
حول ما يحدث هناك ومستجدات
الحصيله وربما
التصريحات من المسؤولين مع مراسل العربيه
زيدان الزنكلو من اسطنبول زيدان هل انت
معنا
نعم نعم انا انا معكم الان مباشره نحن
نتحدث نائب الرئيس التركي فؤاد اوكتاي
يلقي كلمه برفقه وزير الخارجيه مولود
شاويش هو رئيس البرلمان التركي مصطفى
شنتوب الان هناك تحديث لاحصائيات عدد
الضحايا انا معكم واحاول ان انقل ما اسمعه
من نائب الرئيس التركي مباشره انقله عبر
شاشه العربيه نائب رئيس تركيا يتحدث الان
عن ان عدد الوفيات في غازي عنتاب لوحدها
كان حوالي 80 شخص في اضنه هناك عشره اشخاص
في ولايه كهرمان مرعش مركز الزلزال هناك
حديث عن او يؤكد نائب الرئيس التركي ان
هناك 70 وفاه طبعا هذا يعني ان الحصيره
القديمه التي اعلنتها
بشكل عام الحصيله النهائيه الان هي
2006 84
شخص لقوا حذفهم وحوالي
و323 هي هم عدد الجرحى والمصابين مجمل عدد
اعيد بالتذكير هذا الخبر العاجل مجمل عدد
الضحايا في تركيا حتى الان بحسب نائب
الرئيس التركي مئتين واربعه وثمانين شخصا
لقوا مصائهم وعدد الضحايا ارتفع الى
20323 هذا ما اعلنه الان مباشره نائب لهذا
المؤتمر تحديدا زيدان مباشره على الهواء
ابقى معنا
لم تتضرر باي شكل لكن المستشفى القديم في
اسكندرون تعرضت للهدم هنا كان مبنى قديما
العاملون والمرضى المتواجدون هنا تستمعوا
اعمالنا بشانهم في اليمن في منطقه جلباشير
ايضا هناك اضرار كبيره في
مستشفى ايضا هناك
وهناك لن نعيش مشكله بخصوص تامين اللازم
بخصوص المدارس لدينا اخبار جيده
معظم المدارس لم
تتضرر لاضرار هناك مدرسه او مدرستان في
القرى وصلت الينا معلومات بشان تعرضها
للاضرار التقينا تواصلنا مع السيد وزير
التربيه والتعليم والان على والان على وشك
الخروج في طريقه الى المحافظه للتفقد
الاوضاع
انا هنا اشارككم البيانات الرسميه حتى
اللحظه واذا تطورت المعلومات ساشارككم
المعلومات الجديده لله الحمد الاسكانات
الطلابيه كلها والسكان الطلابيه والمدارس
كلها سليمه بالكامل وفق المعلومات التي
وصلت الينا حتى الان وبالتالي فالمدارس
والسكنات الطلابيه
والصالات الرياضيه سيتم استخدامها للاواء
وتستخدم للفعل بخصوص الحاله الجويه
بخصوص المطارات في مطار هاتاي هناك اشكال
والمطار هناك مغلق في مرش وعنتاب تم
اغلاقه مطار في هذين المحافظتين للطيران
المدني في المحافظات الاخرى تستمر حالات
الطيران
بغرض اعمال الانقاذ وتسهيل امور فرق
الطوارئ اما بخصوص الاهتزازات الاعتداديه
فحتى اللحظه يوجد ثمانيه وسبعين
اكبرها كان بدرجه سته فاصله سته بمقياس
وهناك ثمانيه زلازل اكبر من خمسه التي هي
اكبر من خمس درجات من مقياس وهنا انا اذكر
مواطنين المتواجدين في منطقه الكوارث
واؤكد على هذه النقطه
الاهتزازات الابتداديه هي التي لها خطر
فعلي في الحقيقه لان المباني اذا كانت
تضررت ولم تنهدم بعد فهذه اهتزازات
الاكداديه خطروا هدمها لهذه المباني التي
تعرضت لضرر في زلزال الاول هذا الخطر كبير
جدا وبالتالي
تحت اداره وزاره
الاسكاني في تركيا هذه المباني
التي تعرضت لادراك
يتم الاعتناء بها ومهندسون وفرقنا مؤهله
لهذا سيتم التفحص المباني هذه بالكامل اذا
كنتم
تشتبهون في تعرض المبنى لخطر
فاحذروا ان تدخلوا هذا المبنى لا تدخلوه
الا قبل تفقده وبالتالي فهناك ادارات
القائمه
والمحافظات ايضا يمكنكم
مراجعه الدوائر الرسميه وتحقيق التواصل
الفعال الرسمي مع الجهات والدوائر الرسميه
وبخصوص الاتصال
بسبب كثافه الاستخدام في اللحظه الزلزال
الاولى تحدث هناك ازمات احيانا نحن تفرقنا
لهذا مرات كثيره
حول وذكرنا مواطنين بعدم استخدام خطوط
الاتصال الا في حاله الحاجه وان لا يكون
هناك اتصالات طويله
وايضا الاعتماد في الاتصال على الانترنت
احيانا على شبكه الانترنت ربما يكون اسهل
ويحول دون حدوث ازمه في الاتصال الى الان
لم نعش ازمه بهذا الشان في لحظه هناك
مئتين
مركز اتصال متنقل
باداره سته وزارات
مركز اتصال المتحرك تم تحريكها الى تلك
المناطق وبدات العمل وايضا
سيارتي اتصال عاجل
و54 مولدات كهرباء مولدات كهرباء تم
ارسالها الى تلك المناطق للاستخدام العاجل
ايضا هناك امر اخر يعني مواطينا وهو بخصوص
خدمات الاتصال المواطنين الذين تحقق لهم
حاجه عاجله
الذين اغلقت خطوطهم بسبب الديون الفواتير
وغيرها تم التواصل مع
الشركات الاتصال
المعنيه وتم فتح حق خطوطهم للاتصال لكي لا
تكون هناك ازمه وايضا بخصوص توكسيت شبكه
تكسات تم ارسال
مولدات الانترنت مصادق الانترنت تم
ارسالها الى المناطق لتامين اتصال اللازم
اما بخصوص ملف الطاقه فهنا وزاره الطاقه
لها اعمال كثيفه في الساحه في الحقيقه
في العديد من المحافظات في مرش
وعنتاب خط الغاز الواصل بين محافظه
لاضرار وبالتالي غازي عنتاب
وايضا المدن التابعه لها نوردا واصلاحيه
هذه المدن التابعه للمحافظات تم ايقافه
تدفق الغاز الطبيعي اليها حاليا وفي هذا
الاطار الوزاره المعنيه تقوم باعمال
الصيانه
والفحص اللازمين لاعاده وسط تدفق الغاز
الى هذه المدن ايضا في محافظه كلس
خط الغاز الطبيعي تاثر بهذا الضرر لكن
لا زال تدفق الغاز
وفق الغاز المتوفر داخل الخط بالفعل حاليا
لا زاد الاستفاده منهم مستمرا
الشركات التوصيل الغاز الطبيعي في المنطقه
تم تاسيس التنسيق اللازم معهم لعدم لتامين
تدفقي الغازي للافران افران الخبز
والمستشفيات وغيرها من
المحال والمؤسسات والمباني التي تحتاج هذا
التدفق بشكل رئيسي اساسي وعاجل
طبعا
وتامين هذا
بحيث يتاثر مواطنون من هذا الزلزال باقل
تاثيرا ممكن نحن هنا استنفرنا كل قوانا
واستغفرنا كل مساعنا لتقليل لاضرار
المتولده من هذا كما ذكرت خط غازي عنتاب
ومرش خط الغاز الطبيعي الواصل بين هاتين
المحافظتين اعماله بدات وخلال ايام يكون
جاهزا لتدفق الغازي ايضا بخصوص المستشفيات
ذكرت لكم بياناتنا
مستشفياتنا التي مبانيها
المستشفيات التي هي في مبنى قديم بدات
اعماله الفحص
فيها
واذا كان هناك مبنى ثبت تعرضه لضرر
فهنالك المخيمات التي تم تامينها من
المستشفى تقديم خدماته في المناطق القريبه
طبعا هنالك
الكائنات الحيه الاخرى التي تاثرت من
الزلزال الحيوانات
الماشيه المواشي في هذا الاطار
وزاره الزراعه والغابات
اسست لجنه الغذاء والماشية
ويشرف عليها السيد الوزير لتامين حمايه
الحيوانات ضد البردي وضدرها وتضاعف
ومضاعفات الاضرار يتم توصيل الخيم الى تلك
المناطق الى المناطق لتامين حمايه الثروه
الحيوانيه ايضا
تركيا ضمن
اعمال خطه التدخل قامت بجميع خطوات خطه
التدخل التي هي محدده من قبل بتنسيق
واشراف مباشر من اداره افاد وتنسيق محلي
من قبل المحافظات في كل محافظه
والوزارات ايضا بدات اعمال الانقاذ
ونحن هنا نحقق التواصل مع مناطق الكوارث
ننسق التواصل مع المناطق
بخصوص المساعدات تلقينا اتصالات كثيفه من
العديد من الدول
وافدنا وصرحنا
باننا يمكن ان نقول المساعدات الطبيه
ووزاره الخارجيه تواصل التنسيق ذلك شان
ايضا نتلقى
طلبات كثيره من مواطنينا ممن يرغبون في
مساعده اخوانهم
ويقولون ان كيف يمكننا ان نساعد اخواننا
نحن هنا طبعا اتخذنا التدابير اللازمه كلي
لا استغلال
هذا الامر من قبل بعضهم سيتم تنسيق وتامين
توصيل شبكه المساعدات هذه بين التضامن بين
المواطنين وسيتم ايصال هذه المساعدات الى
المحتاجين في هذا الاطار هنالك حسابات
بنكيه سيتم الاعلان عنها في موقعي
لاستقبال المساعدات
ليقوم المواطنين بالمساعدات عبر بوساطه
افاد
ونحث مواطنين على القيام بالمساعده عبر
هذا هذه الشبكه عبر افاد
مره اخرى
اعزي شعبنا واتمنى لهم السلامه
واسال الله ان يقينا مثل هذه الكوارث
نسال الله ان لا يبتلينا بمثل هذه لكنها
نحن نعرف جيدا ان تركيا منطقه زلازل لا
مفر لنا من هذا
وندرك ايضا ان ما يقتل ليس زلزال بل
المباني غير المجهزه للزلزال
ومن ثم فيجب التحضر جيدا للزلزال قبل
الزلزال هذا مهم جدا
ومن هنا نستفيد الدروس اللازمه
نسير وفق نحو تركيا جاهزه امام الزلازل
وبقياده وقياده رئيس جمهوريه مع الوزراء
وان شاء الله نستفيد من هنا درسا كبيرا
لكن ما نركز عليه الان هو حجم التدخل
وتامين ايواء مناطينا وانقاذ من هم تحت
الانقاضي سالمين
هذه اولويتنا
ونقطتنا الاساسيه
تامين الايوائي
والغذائي هذه اولويتها الثانيه طبعا تحقيق
تواصلهم مع اهاليهم والى جانب البنيه
التحتيه ايضا ان شاء الله
ستقف مناطقنا مره اخرى المناطق المتواجده
هذه بعد الزلزال تقف على قدميها مره اخرى
ان شاء الله
معكم الى مؤتمر وكلمه لنائب رئيس التركي
حول الاوضاع في تركيا اثر هذا الزلزال
الذي ضربه اشار بان هناك
284 قتيلا حتى الان واكثر من 2000 جريح
حصيله الزلزال في تركيا حتى الان
وشدد وناشد الناس على عدم استخدام هواتفهم
الا للضروره لعدم لا يحدث اي عطل في شبكات
الاتصال زيدان يعني استمعت معنا الى هذه
التصريحات هناك مدنيين بحسب
النائب رئيس التركي يعني عرضوا المساعده
ما نوع المساعده التي يحتاجونها والتي
يمكن ان يقدمونها حتى اللحظه
لا شك ان نائب الرئيس التركي فؤاد عندما
تحدث عن موضوع المساعدات قال ان المساعدات
هناك جهتان
للمساعدات الجهه الاولى هي الدول التي
عرضت المساعدات وقال الرئيس التركي بان
تركيا طلبه منهم مساعدات طبيه هذا يعني
بان هناك حاجه ربنا سيكون حاجه الى انشاء
مشاكل ميدانيه او دعم المشافي الحاليه او
في حال كما ذكر كان هناك اضرار في المشافي
القديمه سيكون هناك بدائل بمشافي ميدانيه
بالنسبه لما تحدث به عن حملات التبرع
للمواطنين من قبل المواطنين الاتراك لا شك
ان هناك
لا شك ان المئات من الاسر نتيجه انبا دمار
المنازل او تصضع هذه المنازل بقيت بدون
وبالتالي هم بحاجه الى مساعدات عاجله هذا
ما كان يتحدث عنه النائب الرئيس التركي
ولذلك قال ان هذه المساعدات يجب ان تكون
حصرا عبر هيئه الطوارئ والطوارئ عبر
حسابات بنكيه سيتم والاعلان عنها بشكل
رسمي
سنعود الى المؤتمر الصحفي لانه يبدو ان
نائب الرئيس التركيه تلقى اسئله ربما
نستفيد من اجاباتها ابقى مع زيدان طبعا
لكي لا تتاثر على الحياه العامه ويتم
تعطيل المدارس او القيام باجراءات اللازمه
وفقت تطورات طبعا التقينا مع الجهات
اللازمه وعرضنا الامر على السيد رئيس
الجمهوريه بخصوصي هذه المحافظات العشر
بحسب اضرار تاثير اضرار الزلزال سيتم
تعطيل المدارس
سيتم القيام بتصريحات اللازمه اليوم او
غدا في اقصى تقدير اليوم المدارس معطله
بالفعل هذه هذا الاسبوع هذه
تم تعطيل بالفعل لمده اسبوع في هذه
المحافظات العاشقه المتاثره بالزلزال تم
تعطيل المدارس بالفعل لكن فيما بعد ذلك
سيتم تقييم الامر اولا باول
بخصوص السدود كانت هناك بيانات هل من جديد
نحن نقوم
بتفصحص السدود اولا باول في عثمانيه وفي
غيره يتم بالتفقد السدود وتفقد الاضرار
فيها
بخصوص الحريق الذي فيها طي فالمعلومات
التي لدي اين السيد رئيس اداره الكوارث
المعلومات التي هديت تفيد بان الحريق تم
اطفائه
تم اخماد الحريق اذا كان هناك تطور جديد
يمكن ان تشاركوه
بخصوص الدعم الدولي هناك بيانات حول ان
اذربيجان
دعما عربه هناك صحيح هناك طلب من عده دول
لارسال مساعدات الى تركيا لكن نحن في
المرحله الاولى
قدمنا قلنا اننا يمكننا ان نقبل فرق
الانقاذ والدعم الطبي ايضا
حددنا دعما الطلبه الدعم بهذا الاطار
حاليا
ضمن البيانات الواصل الينا لا يوجد اشكال
بخصوص شبكه المواصلات طبعا القرى هي
اولويه هنا
اشكركم جدا
سنشارككم التطورات اولا باول مره اخرى
اتمنى السلامه لشعبنا اذا ذكر نائب الرئيس
التركي بان الدول عده تم التواصل معها
بخصوص المساعدات الطبيه وفرقه الانقاذ وهو
ما يحتاجونهم ما يحتاجونه حاليا
اذربيذا اذربيجان هي من الدول التي ايضا
عرضت المساعده لتركيا زيدان كنا نتحدث عن
هذه المساعدات ونتحدث ايضا عن المساعدات
من المدنيين التي يمكن ان يتم تقديمها
نعم بالفعل قبل ان يخرج لعب الرئيس في هذه
الكلمه كانت هذا الرجال قد
اعلنت عن ارسال او عدمها ارسال فريق
متطوعين
مكون من 370 شخصا من فرق الانقاذ
للمساعده في عمليات
الانقاذ والاخراج الناجيين من تحت الانقاض
هذا ما كانت اعلنت عنه قبل حوالي ساعه من
الان ايضا عدد الدول من بينها السويد ادت
استعدادها لمساعده تركيا في حال طلبات
المساعده لكن كما كان واضحا من النائب
الرئيس التركي فؤاد ان المساعده حاليا
التي تحتاجها تركيا تنحصر فقط في طواقم
الانقاذ وايضا المساعدات الطبيه هذا اكثر
ما تحتاجه الان تركيا
فيما تحدث عنه اعيد واذكر بالحصيله
النهائيه او الحصيره عفوا الاوليه التي
اعلنهار الرئيس التركي بلغت حتى الان بلغ
حتى الان عدد الضحايا 200 و 248 شخصا لقوا
حذفهم او لقوا مصائهم
نتيجه هذا الزلزال في عشر ولايات اكثر
حوالي 2000 او بالضبط
2323 شخص اخرين اصيبوا بجروح باكثر
الولايات التي شهدت عدد من ضحايا هي غازي
عنتاب ب 80 شخص
ماتوا نتيجه او وايضا كارما مرعش 70 وفاه
وايضا عثمانيه 2020 شخصا كل هؤلاء هم اكثر
الولايات التي شهدت وفيات هذا اليوم نتيجه
الزلزال طبعا بالنسبه الى عدد المباني
التي تعذبت قال ان
1710 مباني تهدمت جراء الزلزال وهناك ايضا
تحدث عن 78
ارتداديه عدد كبير من هذه الاجزاء كانت
فوق خمس درجات اشد هذه
الاعزاء السياديه كانت بشده 6.6 درجات نعم
وكان في محيط ولايه غازي عنتاب وهذا ما
ادى على ما يبدو لارتفاع ضبحايا في غازي
عنتاب اكثر من غيرها كان ايضا تحدث عن
انقطاع امدادات الغاز بين كهرمان مرعش
وغازي عنتاب وايضا بين ولايتين غازي عنتاب
وهاتاي وهناك بعض الاضرار في محيط مطار
في جنوب تركيا وايضا تحدث عن توقف ضخ
الغاز الطبيعي بين عنتاب ووعد بان يتم
اصلاح هذه المشكله خلال ايام قليله وايضا
كان هناك
خط الغاز الواصل الى ولايه كلس ايضا تاثرت
لكن العمل في ضغط الغاز ما زال مستمر لا
يوجد اي اضرار فيه بعيدا عنها وايضا اخيره
بما ذكرها
[موسيقى]
وهو تعطي المدارس خلال هذا الاسبوع في
الولايات العاشر ومن ثم عند نهايه الاسبوع
يتم
دراسه الموقف وتقييم الموقف كون هذه
المدارس لا شك انك تستخدم لملاجئ للاشخاص
الذين دمرت منازلهم
او الاشخاص الذين تصدعت المنازل وبالتالي
استحاله العوده الى هذه المنازل لذلك سيتم
تقييم الوضع بالنسبه للمدارس ربما او من
المؤكد ان المدارس اماكن ايواء طبعا بعيدا
عن ما ذكره فؤاد كان هناك حديث او ذكرت
مصادر تركيه عن اغلاق بعض الطرق بين
الولايات التي تضررت نتيجه الزلزال وعلى
سبيل المثال طريق عثمانيا اوثمانيه غازي
عنتاب وايضا بعض الطرق الاخرى بين
الولايات العشره تم اغلاقها وايضا مما
ذكره نائب الرئيس التركي ان المطارات
مطارات غازي عنتاب واتاي وااا
كهرمان عاش مغلقه بالكامل
بينما بقيه المطارات القريبه ما زالت تعمل
فقط في خدمه طرق الانقاذ اي ان هذه
المطارات يعني حسب ما فهمت النائبه الرئيس
التركي توقفت عن استقبال المسافرين
والثقافيه مخصصه
لنقل فرق او طواقم الانقاذ هذا ما يعني
هذا دون تقريبا ما تحدث به لاعب الرئيس
التركي في هذه الاثناء طبعا تتواصل
الجهود الانقاذ والتواصل العاصفه الثلجيه
في عدم من الولايات المتضرره من الفيزياء
كهرمان مرعش وملاقي وهذه عنتاب الثلوج
تتساقط وجهود الانقاذ ما زالت تستمر
لاخراج اكبر عدد من الوصول او الوصول الى
اكبر عدد العالقين تحت الانقاذ وهذه هي
الاولويه التي تحدث عنها
الى جانب المزيد مما تحدث عنه زيدان ابقى
معنا
لنستعرض هذه الصور للمباني التي تتهاوى في
مدينه
في شمال سوريا اثرى هذا الزلزال الذي ضرب
سوريا وتركيا وشعر به كل من لبنان قبرص
ارمينيا اليونان وعدت مناطق حولها اذا هذه
صور وردتنا عن تهاوي المباني في مدينه حلب
شمال سوريا لنستمع
[موسيقى]
زيدان ابقى معنا وسنذهب الى اسطنبول حيث
الصحفي
رامي عبد الرحمن
اهلا بك معنا رامي اذا تحدثنا مع مراسلنا
في تركيا وذكر كيف ان هناك الكثير من
الطرق ستغلق المدارس
صلاه الرياضيه ستستخدم للايواء يعني ربما
الاوضاع مشابهه لما يحدث في سوريا ولكن
سوريا المدارس ايضا تضررت ربما ايضا
الصلاه الرياضيات تضررت ما الخيارات
المتاحه لديهم لايواء المصابين والناجين
من هذا الزلزال نعم قبل ان نبدا من
الخيارات اولا من القاهره وليس من اسطنبول
حقيقه دعينا
نتحدث عن الخسائر البشريه للخسائر البشريه
بشكل قطعي ارتفع العدد الى نحو 350 في
مناطق النظام واكثر من 350 حقيقه الامر
احصائيات يعني غير نهائيه احصائيات حسب
الاحصائيات في مشاكل حلب الغربي في منطقه
عفرين في مناطق النظام نتحدث عن اكثر من
350 بشكل قطعي حتى اللحظه المؤكد للخسائر
البشريه هناك يعني لم نقل الالاف نستطيع
القول بان قد يصل الى الفين ما بين مفقود
وما بين مصاب هناك مباني مثل ما شاهدنا في
حلب
بالصوت والصوره هناك ما لم تتمكن يعني
العدسات الجوالات بالالتقاطها انهارت
نتيجه الهزات ارتداديه نتحدث عن خسائر
بشريه كبيره عن نظام عندما تحدث عن حصيله
نحو 240 ضحيه كانوا في مناطق سيطره النظام
نتحدث نحن فقط في ريف حلب الغربي وفي عف
في الشمال غرب حلب عن اكثر من مئه غير
الذين توفوا في ادلب
تحدثنا سابقا عن نحو 58 منطقه الى اين
سيذهبون هنا الى اين تركيا دوله كبرى في
حلف الناتو ودوله لديها مقومات كامله في
سوريا الى اين سيذهب الذين هربوا بالاساس
هم هاربين من
القفاكهم ايضا تركيا يعني طلبت مساعده من
المجتمع الدولي من سيساعد الذين هم الان
في حلب في ريف حلب الغربي في ريف حلب
الشمالي الغربي في منطقه ادلب هؤلاء في
الاساس هم يعيشون على المساعدات من قبل
المجتمع الدولي يعيشون في خيام يعيشون في
منازل هجروا اليها او اضطروا للنزوح اليها
من مناطق سوريا مختلفه الوضع في سوريا هو
كارثي اكثر بدرجات كبيره من تركيا لانه في
سوريا لا يوجد دوله حقيقه امر تستطيع ان
تساعد هؤلاء السوريين الموجودين سواء في
حلب سواء في مناطق سيطره المعارضه او
السيطره التركيه يجب على المجتمع الدولي
وهذا نطالب حقيقه الامر وندعو الدول
العربيه وجامعه الدول العربيه كون ان
سوريا بالنهايه عربي ان تقدم المساعدات
العاجله وهي سخيه حقيقه الامر وهناك فرق
انقاذ من دول عربيه ساعدت في دول اخرى ان
ترسل الفراخ طبيه الى داخل التراب السوري
كي تساعد السوريين اذا ما كانت تركيا تطلب
المساعدات من سيساعد طلبنا مساعدات من
تركيا على ما يبدو تركيا هي تحتاج الان
لمن يساعدها في عمليات الانقاذ طيب يعني
كيف يمكن ايصال هذه ما ان ارادت الدول ان
تساعد سوريا هل الطرق مفتوحه كيف يمكن
الوصول لهم
هناك هناك امكانيه للوصول الى طرق هناك
شاهدنا بالصوت والصوره نشرتم بالصوت
والصوره كيف هناك منازل باكملها شارع
باكمله المباني تهددت تهدمت على رؤوس
ساكنينها حتى اللحظه الفرق الانقاص تبحث
عن مئات المفقودين لم نقل الاف المفقودين
تحت المباني التي وصلوا اليها وهناك مباني
لم يصلوا اليها قبل قليل كان هناك بعض
القرى التي كان يعتقد البعض بانه لا يوجد
فيها شيء تبين بان هناك مباني تهدمت وان
هناك ضحايا اقول لك بان
كارثه بامتياز يعني عندما نقول بان دمشق
لا يوجد شيء في دمشق نعم دمشق لا يوجد
فيها شيء ولكن في احياء احلام الشرقيه
عندما نشاهد المباني تنهار هل شاهدنا اي
فريق طبي او فريق اسعافي او اي طريق من
اجل فرق انقاذ في تلك المنطقه لم نشاهد
شاهدنا فقط المدنيين ومن يصور تلك المنطقه
اقول انا بصريح العباره يجب على النظام
السوري الان
ولا يخرج علينا باعداد الضحايا لان النظام
من واجبه ان ينقص الضحايا ولا ينفرج علينا
بنشرات ارتفاع الضحايا السيد رامي بان
الوضع بالفعل كارثي ويبدو ان هناك فيديو
لاحد المواطنين في حلب يناشد للمساعده
الى كل جميع فرق الدفاع المدني اللي
بعقربات دعوا يا اهلي
عيال كامله تحت الانقاذ تعالوا
يا أمه محمد
اذا المتضررين في الحلبه السوريه يستغيثون
باي جهات تساعدهم في هذا الوضع الكارثي
يشيرون في مواقع التواصل الاجتماعي بان
سوريا اصبحت منكوبه بان الشمال السوري
اصبح منكوب مئات الاشخاص لقوا مصرعهم في
انهيار الكثير من المباني وعناصر الانقاذ
يعملون على انتشال مدنيين محاصرين تحت
الانقاض في مناطق عده بالقرب من الحدود
التركيه بما في ذلك اعزاز والباب وكما
نشاهد الان ايضا في حلب ويبدو ان المدنيين
يتكاثفون
للمساعده والبحث تحت الانقاذ عن اي احياء
او اي مصابين ما زالوا على قيد الحياه سيد
رامي اعود اليك من الجهه او الدوله الاقرب
والمخوله لان تقدم المساعده
سوريا الان في هذه اللحظات
الدول العربيه يعني المس
اعدات هناك دول قادره على ان تقدم مساعدات
وهي سخيه مقدمه مساعدات للشعب السوري
ولديها امكانياتها الى كالامارات العربيه
المتحده كالمملكه العربيه السعوديه
كجمهوريه مصر العربيه
يجب على النظام ان يفتح هذا الباب لمساعده
السوريين لا ان نقول باننا قادرين على
انقاذ السوريين الارواح السوريين ليست
رخيصه لهذا الدرجه كي يقوم النظام يعني
كيف تركيا دوله عظمى وتطلب عمليه مساعده
من الدول الكبرى والنظام يقول بان الامور
على ما يرام واننا نقوم بواجبنا النظام
ليس لديه فرق طبيه ايضا مناطق الشمال
السوري هذه المناطق التي تستطيع الدول
الاوروبيه ان تقدم ثلث الفريق الطبيه
اليها هذه عندما نشاهد هذا المواطن يقول
يعني
يناشد من يريد ان يناشده من اجل المساهمه
بعمليه الانقاذ هل المواطن المدني يستطيع
انقاذ المدنيين العراقيين تحت الانقاذ
الموصل المد ليس لديه امكانيه للانقاذ
هؤلاء المدنيين قد يقوم بالمساعده ويتسبب
بمقتل من هو تحت الانقاذ هذه المباني
الامر يحتاج الى فرق طبيه متخصصه وانا
اتحدث بواقعيه النظام السوري يجب ان يفتح
ايران قتلتنا ولا تساعدنا ما ليس لدينا
الا الحزب العربي الذي يجب ان يساعد
السوريين الان وعلى النظام ان يطلب
المساعده من الدول العربيه ولا يقف مكتوف
الايدي طيب ابقى معنا سيد رامز ساذهب الان
الى اسطنبول مع الكاتب الصحفي الصحفي فراس
رضوان اوغلو اهلا بك معنا السيد فراس اذا
استمعنا قبل قليل الى نائب الرئيس التركي
وعن تصريحاته والوضع الكارثي في اسطنبول
ايضا اثره الزلزال كيف هي الاوضاع الان
بدايه يعني نقدم التعازي سواء في تركيا او
في سوريا او في اي مكان طالعوا هذا
الزلزال الوضع حقيقه صعب ليس سهلا ابدا
الاحوال الجويه سيئه المساحات الواسعه
التي ضربت فيه هذه الهزه الارضيه وهذا
الزلزال على مساحات كبيره واسعه تحتاج الى
تكاثف اظن كبير ربما سيطلب ايضا مساعده من
الجيش للدخول لانه وزاره الداخليه عبر
وزير الداخليه قال وطلب ان تركيا تريد
مساعدات في هذا السياق الاعداد كبيره
البيوت المهدمه كثيره اظن ان حتى البنى
التحتيه الذي تكلم عنها مساله امدادات
الغاز وامدادات الطاقه وامدادات اخرى كلها
تضررتها تعمل حتى الاتصالات الحمد لله
يعني ما زالت تعمل بشكل جيد انا اتصلت
بكثير من الاصدقاء في الجنوب كلهم يعني
امورهم بخير من ناحيه الاتصالات لكن بعض
الطرق ايضا مغلقه هذه الامور الطرقات التي
هدمت بسبب الزلزال ايضا اظن ان المساله
الطبيه ايضا تشغل تشغل بالداخليه بشكل
كبير لذلك اول ما طلبت طلبه مساعدات طبيه
كثيره
الحقيقه يعني لا اريد ان اقول ان الاحوال
لا تساعد ابدا ولكنها سيئه في هذا السياق
اجا اظن ان يعني ستتضح الامور والمعالم
اكثر
من خلال الساعه اكثر
قبل قليل كنا نتحدث مع سيد رامي وكان يقول
بان كانوا يتوقعون مساعدات من الجانب
التركي ولكن الان تركيا هي من تطالب
بالمساعدات هل هي قادره في هذه الاوضاع ان
تقدم اي شكل من اشكال المساعده لسوريا
يعني انا اظن انها بامكانها يعني لذلك
ربما طلبك مباشره المساعده من الخارج ربما
توزيع هذه المساعده فيما بينها وارسال فرق
موجوده هناك في تلك المناطق انا اظن لا
يوجد حل اخر يعني ان لم تتكاثف الجهود لا
يوجد حل اخر لذلك حتى وصول المساعدات اظن
نعم لان تلك المناطق يعني محسوبه ايضا على
النفوذ التركي ولا يمكن اي تقبل اي تقصير
ربما المناطق التي
لديها اللي تحت
في دمشق الحكومه هناك لا اعلم كيفيه
التعاون في هذا السياق في هذا السياق
الحقيقه ارجو ان لا تدخل السياسه في في
هذا العمل الانساني وهذا ما تكلم به الضيف
قبل قليل لان الوضع لا يحتاج الى اي
احتمالات او تحميل
عبور على اموره ولذلك انا اظن الوضع كارثي
بمعنى الكلمه الوضع سيء بشكل كبير لان
ابتزاز ربما في الولايات الجنوبيه حتى في
البحر بعتقد
او
اسكندرون ومرسين الى الى تلك المناطق حتى
يعني طيب سيد فراس يعني اذربيجان ودول عده
يعني عبروا عن رغبتهم في تقديم المساعده
بتقديرك متى يمكن ان نرى وصول اول دفعه من
المساعدات
يعني انا اظن خلال هذا اليوم سنتصر
مساعدات اذربيجان كونها قريبه جدا على
تركيا وعندها امكانيات قريبه ممكن اظن تصل
بسرعه في في هذا السياق ربما
لا اعلم يعني دول اخرى كانت ساعدت من قبل
كثيرا يعني في مسائل مثل الحريق الكبير
الذي ضرب غرب تركيا روسيا ارسلت مساعدات
حتى اليونان ارسلت مساعدات انا اظن ربما
في هذا الشيء قد اليونان تساعد بلغاريا قد
تساعد روسيا وان كانت تعينه لكن عندها اظن
امكانيه في هذا السياق وطبعا الاعلم الدول
الاخرى التي ستقوم بمساعده الدول العربيه
الدول المجاوره
الارصاد الجويه سيد فراس تتنبا
بعاصفه قادمه ما تاثير هذه العاصفه
والاحوال الجويه على يعني جهود الانقاذ
القائمه ان كان في سوريا او في تركيا لان
العاصفه ستضرب الدولتين
وهذا من سوء الحظ يعني العاصفه ضربت
الدولتين والزلزال ايضا ضربت دولتين يعني
حقيقه يعني الوضع يشرح نفسه انا اظن
بتركيا اظن القدره قويه جدا يعني المطارات
في مناطق متعدده الطرق القدرات الاستعابيه
قويه جدا في تركيا ممكن ان تستخدمها وتحول
الطرقات من مكان لاخر ربما انزال في
مطارات اخرى احتياطيه
ربما اسطنبول في الامس الى مطار واحد لم
يعطل المطار الثاني الكبير مطار اسطنبول
لقدرته القويه لكن انا اظن في تلك المناطق
ربما
سيكون يعني ايجاد الطرق اخرى ينزال في
مناطق اخرى وتوصيلها عبر الشاحنات عبر كذا
لكن المشكله ربما في في سوريا بحد ذاتها
كيفيه وصول هذه المساعدات انا اظن هنا
سيكون لابد من التواصل الاعرم كيفيه هذا
التواصل هل سيكون لروسيا دور في تواصل ان
روسيا قبل قليل اعلنت بان منشاتها
العسكريه لم تتضرر هل ستكون حلقه الوصل
بين على الاقل بين تركيا وسوريا بين سوريا
تركيا دول اخرى ايضا للمساعده ارجو اننا
على الشاشه يعني وزاره الطوارئ الروسيه
تتحدث عن ان استعدادهم لارسال طائرتين الى
تركيا للمساعده في عمليات الانقاذ شكرا لك
الصحفي فراس رضوان اوغلو من اسطنبول ابقى
معنا ونذهب الى القامش لمراسل العربيه
جمعه عكاش اهلا جمعه اذن يعني مناشدات
واستغاثه من قبل المدنيين المتضررين
للمساعده في هذه الاوضاع الكارثيه
ويعني السيئه حقيقه انقل لنا صوره لديك
والانباء الوارده لديك حتى الان
ركام وانقاض المنازل الذين انهارت جراء
الزلزال الذي ظهر يعني مناطق واسعه من
شمال شرق وشمال غرب ومناطق الداخل
السوري صباح اليوم يعني الوضع الانساني
يساوي في ظل نقص الامكانيات سواء كانت
الامكانيات الطبيه او حتى الامكانيات
اللوجستيه الاساسيه من تلك التي تساعد في
رفع الارقام وازالتها وانتشار الاحياء
وحتى المصابين والجهدة من تحت هذه الالقاف
خاصه
في الشمال غرب سوريا حتى منظمه الدفاع
المدني مع بعض الفرق الاهليه والناس
العاديين على ازاله هذه الارقام بطرق
بسيطه وبدائيه جدا وهو ما قد يعني يرفع
عدد يعني القتلى
الضحايا يعني حتى الان احصائيتنا المؤكده
هناك 84 شخص فارقه الحياه في مناطق سيطره
المع
السوريه بينما في مناطق نظام هناك 237 شخص
فقدوا حياتهم معظمهم في مدينه حلب ومدن
طرطوس وحمى واللاذقيه وهما ما يرفع العدد
الاجمالي لعموما فقدوا حياتهم في سوريا
الى 320 شخص طبعا هذه حصيله نهائيه لكن
يمكن ان نقول انها غير يعني قابله لزياده
نتيجه وجود العشره ربما المئات تحت
الارقام خاصه في مناطق الشمال غرب سوريا
وكيف هي الاستعدادات الطبيه وفرق الانقاذ
في القامش للجمعه يعني كيف تقييمك لا
عاليه كافيه هل يحتاجون المزيد هل هي اصلا
موجوده
يعني الخدمات الطبيه والقطاع الطبي بشكل
عام في سوريا هو قطاع سيء منهار نتيجه
ظروف
الحرب المستمر لاكثر من عشر سنوات
مع وجود يعني اللعاب والحدود المغلقه هذا
قد يعني يصعب عمليه ادخال
المساعدات خاصه ان تركيا هي ايضا متضرر
بشكل كبير وفي هذه الحالات نتيجه الجوار
يعتمد عليها في ادخال المساعدات او حتى
نقل الجرحى والمصابين الى المشاء في تركيا
ايضا داخليا يعني الحدود والمعاصر تكاد
تكون شبه مغلقه بين مناطق يعني سيطرت قوات
سوريا الديمقراطيه سيطره المعارضه ومناطق
النظام يعني هناك حاجه لفتح هذه الحدود
والمعابر على الاقل لاحتواء اثار هذه
الازمه الانسانيه لان هناك العشرات وربما
المئات من المصابين خطيره في مناطق سيطره
المعارضه ويحتاج نقلهم الى الى دمشق حيث
المشافي افضل والامكانيات الطبيه افضل من
مناطق المعارضه في شمال الغربي طيب ابقى
معنا الجمعه كرمان انتقل الى احمد مظهر
سعدو صحفي من غازي عنتاب اهلا بك معنا سيد
احمد اذا غازي عنتاب من المناطق المتضرره
كذلك ليس كذلك
كل التحيه لكم ولمشاهدين جميعا لا شك غازي
عنتاب من المناطق المتضرره جدا وخاصه ان
مركز الزلزال هو بالقرب على بعد 26 كلم
منها ومن ثم فان هناك الكثير من الابنيه
تهدمت والناس لا زالوا حتى اللحظه في
الشوارع لا يستطيعون الصعود الى ابنيتهم
لان هناك هزات ارتداديه تجاوز 50 هز
السيازيه بعد الزلزال الكبير الذي راح
ضحيته الكثير من الشعب التركي والشعب
السوري ايضا نعرف ان غازي عنتاب هي مدينه
يوجد فيها ماينوف عن 350 الف سوري من
المهجرين قصرا باتجاه الشمال او باتجاه
تركيا ومن ثم فان المعاناه هي معاناه
السوريين والاتراك على حد سواء وطبعا هناك
العديد من الادوات الانقاذيه الاشتغال
البلديات كان هناك جد عمل جدي حقيقي ساعد
في انقاذ البعض والعوده من جديد باتجاه
حياه امنه وصحيحه لكن باعتقادي ان القضيه
ليست في غازي عنتاب هناك ايضا في جنوب
تركيا الكثير من المناطق الذي يتواجد فيها
السوريون مثل انطاكيا ومرعش وهي ايضا
متضرره الان اثناء حديثنا سيد جمعه مشاهد
وصور ليليه من غازي عنتاب حيث انت تفضل
سيد جمعه
طبعا هذه الصور التي نشاهدها سيد جمعه
تظهر مدى الدمار الذي حصل في المباني
وكميه الناس هناك الذين اتوا ليساعدون
ويحاولون ان ينقذوا ما يمكن انقاذه سيد
جمعه اذا كنت تتحدث بان السيد احمد عفوا
كنت تتحدث بان غازي عنتاب هي بالقرب من
مركز الزلزال في منطقه بازرجيك في محافظه
كهرمان مرعش جنوب شرق وهي مكتظه
بالسكان السوريين المهاجرين او ال ال
النازحين من اماكنهم يعني ما سهوله وصول
المساعدات الطبيه وفرق الانقاذ لمنطقه
غازي عنتاب سيد احمد
يعني بالنسبه لغازي عنتاب بالتاكيد هي
مدينه كبيره جدا ولايه فيها الكثير من
وسائل
التطيب والصحه والمشافي والمستوصفات وهناك
حالات انقاذ كثيره واشتغال جدي فعلا في
هذا السياق المشكله الاساسيه ما يعني
اهلنا في الشمال السوري فعلا اكثر من
تركيا لكن بالتاكيد الشعب السوري والتركي
ايضا عانى معانا منذ ساعات الصباح الاولى
منذ الساعه الرابعه ونصف حتى الان من هذه
هذه الهزه الزلزاليه التي لم يعهد مثل
السوريون ولا الاتراك في هذه المنطقه منذ
زمن طويل وهي اكثر هزه ليس فقط على مقياس
7.8 لكن ايضا
بالامتداد والفتره الزمنيه التي طالت فيها
كثيرا
في الشمال السوري هناك دفاع المدني يقول
بان انتشال ناجين من تحت انقاض المباني في
عفرين شمالي سوريا اذا تم انتشار ناجين من
تحت الانقاذ الشمال السوري بحسب الدفاع
المدني السيد احمد ما الخيارات امام سكان
غازي عنتاب للايواء هل من مدارس هل من
صلاه رياضيه كما ذكرنائب الرئيس التركي
نعم نعم يعني فتحت الصلاه الرياضيه
والمراكز الثقافه في الاعزاء
والتي لا يوجد فيها استقبال الناس وقد
يعني تواجد السلوح متواجدين هذه لكن
اكثر خطا
علاوه على
الكثير من الاماكن
لا استطيع ان اسمعك جيدا سيد احمد يبدو
بانها من تبعات هذا الزلزال ولكن نشير الى
هذا العاجل الذي يريدنا من مصادر تركيا
حيث يشير بان تم توقف العمليات في ميناء
جيهان بسبب الزلزال اذا ميناء جيهان تم
تعطل عن العمل بسبب هذا الزلزال ننتقل
الان الى ابراهيم الادلبيه صحفي من الحدود
السوريه التركيه اهلا بك معنا سيد ابراهيم
الحدود التركيه السوريه التركيه حيث انت
كيف هي الاوضاع هناك انقل لنا الصوره اهلا
وسهلا بك وبجميع المشاهدين حقيقه نعم
الوضع حاله ماساويه تعم المنطقه الشماليه
بعمرو المنطقه الشماليه والشماليه الغربيه
والشماليه الشرقيه من سوريا اضافه الى
جنوب تركيا نتحدث حتى الان عن حصيله غير
نهائيه
125 مدني كانوا قد لقوا حتفهم جراء هذا
الزلزال النصيب الاكبر كان لمدينه الاتاري
بريف حلب هناك او اكثر من خمسين مدني
كانوا قد لقوا حتفهم جراء انهيار الابنيه
السكنيه اضافه الى اكثر من 350 حاله مصاب
وطبعا اتحدث عن ارقام غير نهائيه وغير
دقيقه مئه بالمئه هذا ما تمكنا من الحصول
عليه من النقاط الطبيه وبعض المصادر وايضا
المستشفيات وعمليات النقل ما تزال هناك
الكثير من المدنيين العالقين تحت الانقاط
تحت ركام المنازل المهدمه في المنطقه
الشماليه الغربيه من سوريا الحكومه
السوريه المؤقته اعلنت حاله الطوارئ
الدفاع المدني يلعب رئيس حرب بعمليه اخراج
المدنيين من تحت الانقاب
الامكانيات المحدوده التي يمتلكها اضافه
الى فرق المنظمات الانسانيه والمدنيون
الذين يشاركون بالادوات البدائيه من اجل
ابعاد الانقاذ عن المدنيين يتحدث عن مناطق
منكوبه بشكل كامل الاتاري اتحدث عن سرمدا
اتحدث عن مدينه حارم وايضا سلقين المناطق
القريبه من الحدود السوريه التركيه النقاط
هناك النقاط الطبيه تكتظ باعداد كبيره من
المصابين الحالات الحرجه التي يتم ادخالها
الى تركيا عبر المشاريع والتنسيق ما بين
المشاكل السوريه والمشاكل التركيه هنا
المدنيون المنتشرون في الاراضي الزراعيه
او في المناطق الخاليه البعيده عن المشاهد
السكنيه خشيه من هزات ارتداديه متواصله
ومستمره هنا مشفى عفرين ومشفى الباب وايضا
بعض المشافي على النقاط الحدوديه وصلت الى
الطاقه الاستيعابيه الكبرى لعداد المصابين
هناك مصابين ينامون في
الكاليدورات المستشفيات بحسب بسبب عدم
وجود اسره الكادر الطبي مستنفذ المستنكر
منذ الساعه الرابعه صباحا اليوم حتى هذه
اللحظه ايضا الدفاع اتحدث عن الفصائل
العسكريه التي قامت بتقديم الاليات
العسكريه واليات النقل من اجل ارداف
المدنيين لانها حاله حاله عاجله تعم كافه
المناطق والمؤسسات
المؤسسات الحكوميه والغير الحكوميه
والمنظمات وحتى المدنيين معنيون في هذا
الحدث الجميعي يشارك كانه حقيقه يوم
المحشره الجميع يشارك بعمليه الانتشار
الانقاذ الجميع يشارك بعمليه نقل المصابين
الجميع يحتاج الى خدمات ويساهم بعمليه
التقديم لانها حاله عامه نتحدث عن
المدنيون الذين باتوا في العراء
بالتزامن مع وجود منخفض جوي كان قد ضرب
المنطقه منذ صباح الامس حتى هذه اللحظه
عمليه تساقط الثلوج اي انقطاع الشوارع او
اغلاق الشوارع بسبب تراكم الثلوج الفرق
المخلوقات سيد ابراهيم عن قدوم عاصفه ايضا
شديده ستضرب سوريا وتركيا كيف تتوقع تاثير
ذلك على عمليات الانقاذ القائمه هذا سيعمق
حقيقه الكثير من جروح المدنيين اليوم
نتحدث عن المدنيين عامه في سوريا وتركيا
دعينا دعينا نمسح الحدود السوريه التركيه
لان الحدث هو واحد عمليه الجول
هم من المدنيون الانقاذ هناك ابنيه حقيقه
للاسف كانت قد هدمت او نزلت بعلاقاتينها
بامكان في سوريا او حتى في تركيا بعض
المشاكل في تركيا بناء على المعلومات
الرسميه التي صدرت على الحكومه هناك
مستشفيات اصبحت على الارض سويت على الارض
جراء الزلزال ان كان في انطاكيا وبعض
المدن التركيه وايضا هناك النقاط الطبيه
في سوريا التي سويت على الارض بمن فيها
للاسف من مدنيين وكوادر طبيه او هذه
النقاط بالاساس نتحدث عن بنيه تحتيه مهدمه
مضعضعه في شمال غرب سوريا هذه البنيه
التحتيه التي لم تتعرض لاي عمليه اعاده
ترميم او اعمار منذ ما يقارب 12 سنه جراء
العمليات العسكريه اضافه الى المدنيين
المنتشرون في الخيال العاصفه التي تحدثتي
عنها التي ضربت المنطقه منذ صباح الامس
ومستمره الى ما بعد ثلاثه ايام بحسب
الخبراء الجويين درجات الحراره قد تصل الى
ما دون في المنطقه الشماليه الغربيه من
سوريا مع استمرار تساقط الثلوج والمدنيون
المتواجدون في العراق ان كان تحت الاشجار
او منهم من حول التوجه باتجاه الخيام
المنطقه الشماليه السوريه المنطقه
الشماليه الغربيه عفوا على الحدود السوريه
التركيه وذلك لمحاوله الاحتماء من الثلج
لانه قد ادركوا ان سقطت الخيمه هو امر
مختلف عن سقوط الاماكن التي كانوا يسكنون
في اول مباني السكنيه بالنسبه للملاجئ ليس
هناك الكثير من الملاجئ في المنطقه
الشماليه الغربيه من سوريا التي كانت
تستخدم بوقت سابق للاهتمام من عمليات
القصف الجوي او عمليات العسكريه اليوم
اصبحت مكتظه ولا يمكن الحديث عن دخول
المزيد من المدنيه
وايضا المستشفيات يبدو بحسب مصادر وعاجل
وردنا قبل قليل ايضا بعض المستشفيات بدات
تصل الى طاقتها القصوى ابقى معي سيد
ابراهيم سانتقل الى السيد فراس رضوان مره
اخرى سيد فراس يعني
النائب الرئيس التركي عبر عن مخاوف من
الهزات الارتداديه التي وصلت الى 78 هزا
ارتداديه حتى الان بالتالي يعني في ظل كل
ما يحدث ما هي الاستعدادات التي يقومون
بها لتجنب اي اضرار اكثر اي وفيات اكثر هل
يتم يعني مطالبه السكان من الخروج من
المباني القديمه المستشفيات القديمه وما
الى ذلك
نعم هو قال ان هناك لجان هندسيه تتجه الى
كل المناطق المتضرره لتفحص هذه الابنيه
التي تضررت واغلب الابنيه التي تضررت هي
التي ربما قديمه ولكن لا تناسب وضع
الزلزال والزلازل ولذلك وهي كثيره حقيقه
في تركيا هناك كان مشروعا كبيرا جدا في
تركيا اعاده بناء المدن كلها على اعاده
تهيئتها لتكون مضاده للزلازل اي هدف
البيوت القديمه وانشاءها بشكل كبير ولكن
هذا يحتاج الى كثير من الوقت الازمه
الاقتصاديه اظن اثرت كثيرا لم يستمر هذا
المشروع رغم يعني نتكلم عن عشر سنوات
تقريبا هذا المشروع لكن لا اظن انه استمر
بشكل جيد بسبب الازبه الماليه الخلافات في
بعض الامور لذلك هو قال الاهتزاز
الارتداديه قد تؤثر على البيوت التي هي
متضعضعه نوعا ما فياثر فيها هذا الزلزال
اظن ان الناس هي متخوفه لا احد سيعود الان
الى بعد اقل من 24 ساعه حتى تتضح الصوره
بشكل واضح طبعا تم فتح كثير من
المؤسسات والملاعب
والصالات وغيرها لايواء هؤلاء الناس ادى
اظن ان الوضع سيء يعني لا يمكن الان ان
نقول ان الدوله التركيه قادره على نسيطر
على الوضع لا يتضح هذا الوضع بعد النداءات
المساعده اظن انها تحتاج الى المساعده
لذلك
[موسيقى]
المشكله الاخرى هي ايضا اعاده بناء هذه
البيوت مره اخرى للكثير نحن نتكلم على هو
الان قالوا 1960 الوضع الاقتصادي الذي
تحدثت عن سيد فراس الوضع الاقتصادي السيء
للبلاد منذ سنوات يعني ربما سيكون من
الصعب اعاده البناء واعاده يعني تشييد هذه
المباني بشكل يتحمل الزلازل كما حضرتك
تفضلت ولكن يبقى الاهم الان هو توفير
المساعدات وفرق الانقاذ والمعدات الطبيه
للحالات المصابه وللناجين من هذه الزلازل
ابقى معي سيد فراس سانتقل واعود الى
القامشلي ومراسل العربيه جمعه عكاش جمعه
عندما تحدثنا قبل قليل ذكرت بان الكثير من
الطرق يتم اغلاقها بسبب يعني الوضع
الكارثي الذي تشهده البلاد ولكن كيف هي او
ما هي سبل توصيل المساعدات ماء وصلت الى
المناطق المتضرره
يعني عاده المساعدات الانسانيه التي تتجه
الى سوريا يعني تاتي من من ثلاثه محاور
اما من تركيا او من اقليم كردستان العراق
او من الاردن المعبر الوحيد الذي يعمل
حاليا
في يعني بين سوريا والكردستان العراق
ومعبر
سيمالكا مع الاغلاق التام بمعبر اليعربيه
بينما هناك عده معابر بين سوريا
وتركيا مفتوحه خاصه معبر باب الهوى يتوقع
ان تدخل المساعدات الانسانيه في حال
قدومها من من معبر باب الهوى لتصل الى
المناطق الاكثر تضررا في شمال غرب سوريا
تحوي الغربي لبلده
عفرين لكن حتى الان لا توجد اي يعني
قرارات على المستوى الدولي يعني ارسال
مساعدات طارئه الدولي تحديدا وزاره
الطوارئ الروسيه اعلنت الان عن طائرتان
تحملان فريق بحث وانقاذ او فرق بحث وانقاذ
من 100 شخص جاهزتان للسفر الى تركيا اذا
يبدو ان اولى دفعات المساعدات ستصل من
الجانب التركي بحسب وزاره الطوارئ الروسيه
عفوا من الجانب الروسي ام طائرتان تحميلان
فرق بحث وانقاذ من 100 شخص جاهزتان للسفر
الى تركيا جمعه هل من جديد حول عدد
الوفيات عدد الجرحى هل تم انتشال المزيد
من الجثث او ربما المجيد المزيد من
المصابين من تحت الانقاذ حتى الان جمعه
نعم نحن نتواصل بشكل مستمر مع المشافي
الميدانيه والعيادات
المنتجه في المناطق المنكوبه الاعداد على
مستوى سوريا على مستوى عموم سوريا 320
اضافه الى عدد لا يمكن احصائه من المصابين
لان عمليات انتشال يعني
البحث على المفقودين تحت الانقاض وتشال
يعني المصابين تحت الاقراض عمليات مستمره
وهؤلاء يستغرقون الوقت حتى يصلوا الى الى
سؤال مشافي الميدانيه الصغيره او العيادات
الصغيره في القرى والاقضيه او الى المشاكل
الكبيره في المدن الرئيسيه خاصه النجفي
سرمده
عفرين العسكري نحن نتحدث عن 320 شخص فقدوا
حياتهم الاف ولربما الاف الاصابات
المختلفه من حيث النوع الحجر
طيب ابقى معي جمعه سانتقل الى سيد احمد
سعدو من غازي عنتاب اهلا بك سيد احمد مره
اخرى اذا وزاره الطوارئ الروسيه اعلنت عن
طائرتان
للمساعده تحمل قرابه 100 شخص من الانقاذ
والمساعده لتركيا مستعده لان تتجه الى
تركيا اذا يبدو اننا فقدنا الاتصال مع سيد
احمد سانتقل الى سيد ابراهيم الادلبي من
الحدود السوريه التركيه السيد ابراهيم
الوزاره وزاره الطوارئ الروسيه تعلن عن
طائره جاهزه للانطلاق الى تركيا الان ما
نصيب سوريا من هذه المساعدات
اهلا وسهلا تمرين جديد بالنسبه لموضوع مد
العون والمساعده كانت قد اعلنت عن الحاله
الرابعه من حاله الطوارئ وهذا يعني انها
بحاجه الى مساعده دوليه كما تركى بحاجه
الى مساعده دوليه سوريا ايضا بحاجه الى
مساعده دوليه خاصه نتحدث عن او كما تحدث
مراسلكم في وقت سابق ان هناك سلطات امر
واقع في المنطقه الشماليه الغربيه
والشماليه الشرقيه واضافه الى دمشق هؤلاء
الثلاثه غير قادرون حقيقه على اداره هذا
هكذا حاله مستعجله بسبب الزلزال الذي ضرب
وكل تركيا وكل امكانياتها كانت قد اعلنت
المرحله الرابعه لنكن واقعيين اكثر
المنطقه الشماليه الغربيه الملاصقه لمدينه
غازي عنتاب وهي القريبه من مركز الزلزال
المتضرر الاكثر من هموم الاراضي السوريه
هناك ما تحدثت عن 125 قتيل نصيب المنطقه
الشماليه الغربيه من سوريا اعداد القتلى
في سوريا عامه وصلوا الى 327
على اراضي السوريه من وصولا من حلب الى
اللاذقيه طرطوس وحماه هذه المدن الكبرى
اضافه الى ادلب وريف حلب الشرقي المنطقه
الشرقيه هي الاقل تضررا احاديث وزاره
احاديث وزاره النقل او حديث الروسي عن
ارسال 100 شخص من اجل المساهمه بعمليه
انقاء الانقاذ والمسام بعمليه ازاله
الانقاذ قد يكون بدوافع انسانيه لن نتحدث
الان بشكل سياسي او عن الخلاف ما بين
الشعب السوري وما بين القوات الروسيه التي
كانت قد امنت في قتل السوريين الان نحن
نتحدث عن حال انسانيه مستعجله وهي انقاذ
العالقين تحت الالقاب فرق الدفاع المدني
وكل امكانياتها اضافتها الامكانيات
الموجوده وايضا امكانيات التركيه التي
كانت تساهم بداخل الاراضي السوريه لم لم
تصل الى المستوى المطلوب لان ما يزال
العالقون منذ الساعه الرابعه الى هذه
الساعه وانا اتحدث
تعمل من اجل الانتشار في عم المناطق
المتضرره ان كان في تركيا وفي سوريا على
مشاهد على الشاشه امامنا سيد ابراهيم
مباشره وغير مباشره وسابقه عن فرق الانقاذ
وما يقومون به لانقاذ ما يمكن انقاذه شكرا
لك ابراهيم الادلبي صحفي من الحدود
السوريه التركيه ومن غازي عنتاب احمد مظهر
سعده
والمراسل مراسل العربيه من القامشلي جمعه
عكاش شكرا لكم جميعا مستمرين معكم
مشاهدينا مستمرون في هذه التغطيه معكم
واترككم مع زميلي نايف الاحمري